في كمين نصبه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بشقه في بنايه قيد الانشاء قرب حاجز صرا
العسكريا جنوب غربي نابلس كان اربعه من
مقاتلين مجموعات عارين الاسود في مرمى
نيران الاحتلال خلال اشتباك المسلح ادى
الى استشهاد ثلاثه منهم واعتقال الرابع
ومصادره قطع سلاح وذخيره
كنا نايمين يعني فجاه سمعنا صوت اطلاق نار
كان كثيف جدا يعني من قبل جنود
الاسرائيليه طلعنا على الشباك نشوف شو فيه
يعني لقينا سياره صافيه موجوده هون
والثلاث شباب كانوا على الارض
بينما عم اضراب تجاري جزئي في مركزها حزنا
على سقوط الشهداء الثلاثه برصاص الاحتلال
فصائل فلسطينيه دانت جريمه الاحتلال
الجديده واعتبرت انها تاتي في سياق الحرب
الشامله والمفتوحه التي تشنها حكومه
الاحتلال بحق الفلسطينيين ومقاومتهم
بدورها تبنت مجموعات عارين الاسود شهدائها
الثلاثه وتوعدت الاحتلال بالثار لهم امام
هذا الوعيد هدد رئيس حكومه الاحتلال
العائد من زياره رسميه لروما في جلسه
حكومته الاسبوعيه بقتل من يحاول المس
بمواطن اسرائيل
باسم الحكومه اسرائيل من اجل الشفاء
العاجل لجرح العمليه القاسيه امس الاول في
تل ابيب واؤدي التحيه للمتطوع وللمقاتلين
الذين قضوا على المخرب لقد اوعزنا بهدم
منزله واعتقلنا والده مع متورطين اخرين في
هذه العمليه القاسيه
سنحاكمهم وننزل بهم العقاب مثل ما نرى فان
قواتنا تعمل على مدار الساعه ضد كل ما
يريد المساس بحياتنا والمبدا بسيط جدا فمن
يحاول الاضرار بنا فدمه في راسه
وباستشهاد الشبان الثلاثه ترتفع حصيله
الشهداء الفلسطينيين منذ بدايه هذا العام
الى اكثر من 80 شهيدا في جميع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بين وعيد المقاومه الفلسطينيه
بالثار لشهدائها وتهديد حكومه الاحتلال
بالقضاء عليها يزداد الوضع توترا على نحو
يجعله على حافه الانفجار على جميع
المستويات سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره نابلس
فلسطين